[Musik]
herzlich willkommen und frohe ostern
trotz normalerweise wären die meisten
von uns jetzt unterwegs vielleicht sogar
in den ferien irgendwo im süden aber wir
sitzen zu hause und das bereits seit
vier wochen
manche fühlen sich einsam andere
eingeengt einige miss langweilig andere
sind überfordert und gestresst weil man
so wie ich zum beispiel zu hause
arbeiten und gleichzeitig die kinder
betreuen muss hinzu kommen bei vielen
menschen existenzielle ängste um die
eigene gesundheit oder um den
arbeitsplatz wie schaffen wir es in
dieser ausnahmesituation unser
psychisches gleichgewicht die innere
balance nicht zu verlieren das will ich
von meinen heutigen gästen wissen
steffi weit ist fachärztin für
psychiatrie und psychotherapie und
leitende ärztin am zentrum für
depressionen angsterkrankungen und
psychotherapie der psychiatrischen
universitätsklinik zürich und andreas
maercker ist professor am
psychologischen institut der universität
zürich und ein führender experte wenn es
um traumata und um psychische
altersbeschwerden geht herzlich
willkommen in beiden ja wie steht es
denn um ihr psychisches gleichgewicht in
dieser ausnahmesituation erstaunlich gut
auch für mich ist das natürlich eine
ungewohnte situation auch bei uns in der
klinik zum beispiel ist es natürlich ein
vollkommen anderes arbeiten als wir das
normalerweise gewohnt sind was man etwas
kunkel
das heißt konkret dass wir zum beispiel
verschiedene teams haben das wir
stationen haben wo speziell für
patienten die positiv getestet sind aber
auch speziell stationen haben für
menschen die besonderen schutz bedürfen
also risikopatienten und dass wir
normalerweise arbeiten wir eher ich sage
jetzt mal thematisch also spezielle
station für menschen mit depression
spezielle stationen für menschen mit zum
beispiel suchterkrankungen
jetzt haben wir das mehr oder weniger
gemischt weil wir ganz andere
voraussetzungen
haben wie wir menschen schützen müssen
und das heißt da haben wir andere
herausforderungen als wir das
normalerweise haben
gleichzeitig habe ich den eindruck man
meistern wir das gut in der klinik aber
auch in meiner familie meistern wird als
gut
da habe ich vielleicht das glück dass
mein mann sowieso immer im home office
arbeitet und für ihnen das gar nicht
wahnsinnig neu ist und er auch viel mehr
als sonst die kinderbetreuung übernimmt
und von daher muss ich sagen habe ich
den eindruck ich als person aber auch
die familie aber auch mein background im
sinne meines berufs meister das gut herr
merkel wie ist das bei ihnen geht eben
erste gut in dieser situation ja ich
würde es ja so ein bisschen im
zeitverlauf sehen also zu anfang da war
es schon schwierig noch so klare
gedanken zu fassen das hat eben mit der
umorganisation der arbeit zu tun völlig
auf home office das team alle sind im
home-office dann sich herumschlagen mit
den neuen digitalen techniken das hat
dann auch hektik erzeugt und zusätzlich
zu den ängsten und zu den zu den
schlimmen eindrücken die man irgendwie
verarbeiten musste also es ist über die
zeit besser geworden und wir müssen
natürlich bei uns auch in unserem
ambulatorium für psychotherapie vieles
um organisieren dass alle allerwenigsten
ist jetzt noch sprechzimmer therapie und
dann mussten wir die rechtlichen
bestimmungen einhalten die müssten
erstmal ausgearbeitet werden um eben
auch über distanz digital psychotherapie
anzubieten aber ich freue mich jetzt das
irgendwie jetzt doch nach der zeit ist
klare gedanken wieder gibt wir wollen
heute ein bisschen über die psychischen
folgen dieser krise sprechen was das mit
uns macht es gibt ein berühmten
vergleich des philosophen
arthur schopenhauer der einmal gesagt
hat der mensch ist wie ein
stachelschwein und den kalten
jahreszeiten müssen die ganz nah
zusammen um die wärme zu spüren aber sie
dürfen nicht zu nahe sonst pieksen sie
sich und es tut weh
wie passend ist dann dieses bild herr
merker für den menschen ich kam erst mal
ein bisschen meine erkenntnis zu stoppen
aber raus und würde sagen der war ja nun
wirklich auf das tierleben auch relativ
fixiert er hat ja vieles sondern seinen
philosophischen gedanken mit den tieren
gemacht und wir wissen dass solche
analogien immer auch ein bisschen hängen
und klar wir müssen uns verändern jetzt
in solchen schwierigen zeiten ist ein
krisenmodus das tut gut es immer mal
wieder sich selber auch zu sagen aber
ich selber kann jetzt nicht so ganz viel
mit dieser metapher anfang dass wir da
wie die schachtel schweine uns
aneinander rollen und dann auch pieksen
ja ich glaube er wollte darauf hinweisen
das ist sowas wie dichte stress
eventuell gibt da können wir ja
vielleicht nachher noch darüber reden
ich selber glaube übrigens das ist auch
kein guter ja auch kein guter begriff
ist alle aus dem tierreich kommt aber ja
dass wir schon in einer anderen zeit
sind und ja wir müssen uns einschränken
also wir müssen uns so was wie
zusammenrollen da wir die schuppen aber
zustimmen wir müssen gewisse verzichte
machen diejenigen von uns die noch auf
der arbeit sind also immer noch zur
arbeit fahren vielleicht noch weniger
oder gar nicht aber die anderen die home
office haben und wie sie es gesagt haben
dann mit der ganzen familie vielleicht
kleinen kindern zusammen sitzen dann
dann ist das so ein eingeschränkter
zustand aber können wir in dieser krise
etwas über den menschen über das
menschsein lernen dass wir da vorher
nicht so klar gesehen habe
sicher auf vielen ebenen und ich glaube
dass wir doch gemerkt haben wie viele
von uns erschüttert sind wie viele von
uns da auch große mitleid empfinden
müssen und wir müssen natürlich lernen
dass es dinge gibt die wir uns vorher
überhaupt noch nicht gedacht haben ich
weiß nicht wer wirklich schon so eine
vision davon hatte dass diese pandemie
also wirklich weltweite epidemie
und sie alle treffen wird und wir können
dann auch lernen dass das irgendetwas
mit natur zu tun hat es gibt ja so die
idee da irgendwie die natur schlägt
zurück
also es sind dinge passiert auf die wir
uns völlig neu einstellen müssen
fried die gegenwärtige situation ist
eine ausnahmesituation krisenmodus haben
sie gesagt
das heißt die meisten von uns sind zu
hause wir sehen unsere liebsten nur über
bildschirme die freunde auf zwei meter
distanz ist das eine eine lebensform an
die wir uns theoretisch kulturell
gewöhnen könnten oder widerspricht das
fundamental menschlichen
grundbedürfnissen also zum teil sind wir
es vielleicht schon gewohnt gewesen denn
wir haben unsere beziehungen sind heute
international auch unsere persönlichen
beziehungen
das ist jetzt vielleicht etwas
intensiver als normalerweise
gleichzeitig denke ich es gibt so
gewisse fundamentale dinge die werden
sich nicht ändern also die gerade die
die jetzt allein leben oder die werden
natürlich vermissen dass die freunde da
sind die werden natürlich vermissen das
auch mal die freunde sie in den arm
nehmen denn die haben einfach wenn sie
nicht das glück einer familie oder einer
wg zum beispiel haben wo man sowieso auf
engem raum lebt ist das etwas was sie
sehr fundamental vermissen werden im
moment genauso ältere leute die zu ihrem
schutz jetzt zu hause bleiben müssen
auch die vermissen natürlich die familie
die
angehörigen und haben dann auch noch den
nachteil dass sie nicht mal immer der
technik mächtig sind um wirklich
überhaupt videotelefonie zb machen zu
können
wie lange können wir diesen wieder
natürlichen zustand haushalten
ja das ist sehr schwer abschätzbar denn
wir haben wir sind ja in so einer
situation tatsächlich noch nie wirklich
gewesen oder was wir wissen und wo wir
wissen dass es solche ähnlichen
situationen selbst gewählte ähnliche
situationen gibt ist zb bei
polarforschern die dort an den polen
überwintern
die sind ja von ihren liebsten getrennt
sind auf sehr engem raum miteinander
manchmal auch mit leuten die sie
vielleicht gar nicht unbedingt schätzen
und genau so sehen wir das in der
raumfahrt auch dort sind ist man auf
sehr engem raum und aber auch dort sieht
man dass es nach wenigen wochen dazu
führt man man hat schon begriff dazu
geprägt grad an den polen die josty also
wie im toaster gemeinsam zusammen
gefährlich zu sein was nicht nur positiv
ist was zu gewissen ja vielleicht auch
depressiven gefühlen führt was zu
lustlosigkeit führt was manchmal auch
dazu führt dass man gewisse so
aggressive gedanken gegenüber den
anderen anfängt zu hegen
und das obwohl man das freiwillig macht
obwohl man das selbst gewählt hat und
nun haben wir es nicht mal gewählt
sondern es wird uns aufgezwungen zurecht
aufgezwungen und das ist sicherlich eine
situation die wir nicht sehr lang
aufrecht genau diese aggression also man
hat ja gelesen die häusliche gewalt
nimmt zu es gab auch diesen egoismus wir
denken an die hamsterkäufe am anfang
gleichzeitig gibt es diese solidarität
nachbarschaftshilfe was jetzt verstärkt
diese krise das gute oder schlechte
menschen oder oder beides beides beides
also manches tritt daneben hervor und
jetzt müsste man schauen was ist das
gute was hervorschaut und was ist das
das schlechtere was davor schaut
ich denke es werden auch ein paar
bestimmte typen von menschen
auch größere schwierigkeiten haben
impulsive menschen aber auch die
menschen die man landläufig narzissten
nennt oder die narzisstisch veranlagung
haben also die eigentlich immer eine
bestätigung durch andere brauchen die
dass sie draht nach sich sehnen und
drängen durch andere gelobt zu werden
oder durch andere ja heraus gestellt zu
werden
die laufen ins leere oder man holt sie
sich im internet die bestätigung ja das
kann man machen aber das reicht dann
vielleicht auch nicht weil denen dann
die diese persönliche dimension fällt
also jetzt bin ich schon wieder ins
negative gekommen aber positives schon
auch also ich glaube wirklich so eine
eine welle von mitgefühl ist da ist es
eine ein großes verständnis auch was ich
eine sehr gute sache findet dass das
alles sehr komplexe sachverhalte sind
und dass man das nicht mit 1 mit
einfachen lösungen machen kann
und ja auch vertrauen darin dass zb die
politischen entscheidungsträger der
bundesrat kantonale behörden
institutionen die wissenschaftler auch
gut entscheiden obwohl wir das als laien
nicht nachprüfen können also ich glaube
es ist ein hervorkommen von sowie von
negativen als auch von positiven dingen
und wir dieses gute bleiben wenn die
maßnahmen gelockert werden die die
solidarität dieses vertragen alles
sicher nicht und wir haben aus der
trauma folgen forschung wissen wir dass
es so etwas gibt wie ein ein gefühl das
man nennt posttraumatische reifung oder
pass dramatisches wachstum dass menschen
denken wenn wir jetzt etwas
schreckliches durchgemacht haben
dann merken wir an uns das hat uns
verändert
es hat uns verändert weil wir kleine
dinge des lebens mehr schätzen
vielleicht blumenstrauß mehr schätzen
als man ihn vorher schon mal geschätzt
hat weil wir wissen wie wichtig es ist
mit anderen menschen zusammen zu sein
nun ist es so bei diese
posttraumatisches reifung ist nun auch
meistens nicht fürs ganze leben sondern
die hört dann auch nach einer zeit
wieder auf also ich fand daher denke ich
wir sollten zuversichtlich sein das ist
eine weile lang einiges noch bei uns
bleiben wird aber vielleicht auch nur
weil eine weile lang die negativen
folgen
das heißt kann so eine art verbunden hat
auch entstehen durch die krise also wie
man kennt das ja aus beziehungen wenn
man strenge zeit geschäftlich schwierige
zeit hat man danach das gefühl irgendwie
wieder enger zusammen zu sein
ja ich glaube schon und ich würde das
gerne versuchen wir auch vom einzelnen
individuum dass wir versuchen mal zu
betrachten was schaffen wir eigentlich
auch als zivilisationen im moment und
wir müssen uns bewusst werden wir
schaffen im moment etwas was ich den
eindruck habe wir zu keinem zeitpunkt
früher in unserer entwicklungsgeschichte
geschafft haben wir stehen nämlich
natürlich es gibt immer die die meckern
und immer die die irgendwas besser
wissen aber wir stehen im moment sehr
gern zusammen und am anfang gab es viele
nationalistische strömungen meine maske
deine maske aber im moment es wird
ausgetauscht es wird geholfen es wird
über nationale grenzen hinweg geholfen
und wir sind als zivilisation also wenn
wir auch nur teile davon weiter bringen
könnten
haben wir uns als zivilisation sehr sehr
viel weiter entwickelt in dieser sehr
sehr kurzen zeit denn wir stehen
zusammen es ist nicht das recht des
stärkeren im moment was zählt sondern es
ist der zusammenhalt erzielt es ist der
schutz der schwächeren der im moment
zählt und das ist doch etwas was sehr
sehr positiv ist ich hätte gerne eine
sache noch anschließend nämlich das ist
wohl die erste solche überhaupt in der
welt ist in der wir auch aufgrund des
weiten wohlstand in europa und teilen
der welt um jeden einzelnen in
lebensgefahr
kämpfen können und jeden einzelnen
medizinisch wirklich versuchen so gut
wie möglich zu behandeln
und das ist
das gab es vorher nicht also die letzte
große epidemie aber auch leider
epidemien dies in afrika gab da ging es
nicht mehr dann zum schluss um einzelne
natürlich ist das heute auch nicht auf
der ganzen welt und gestern haben gerade
aus ecuador einem sehr armen land bilder
da ist es dann eben nicht mehr so aber
ansonsten fast auf der ganzen welt
einschließlich aller asiatischen staaten
und das gab es vorher nie
ja das heißt aber auch wir sind hier in
einer relativ privilegierten situation
aus das gesundheitssystem angeht wenn
jetzt an afrika oder an andere
entwicklungsländer denken in südostasien
usw
und trotzdem diese krise macht der
vielen vielen als derzeit
und ich glaube ein wichtiger auslöser
dieser angst waren die bilder aus
norditalien die wir alle im kopf haben
nicht mehr vergessen können etwa die
bilder aus bergamo in der kirche des
friedhofes reihen sich die lage
mittlerweile schier endlos aneinander
denn in den städtischen leichenhallen es
nicht mehr genügend platz vorhanden
vom massensterben überfordert lässt sich
die stadt von der armee unterstützen
nachts fährt das militär särge in die
krematorien der provinz das eigene ist
überlastet
im städtischen krankenhaus ist die
hälfte der 1000 betten von kubik 19
patienten besetzt arzt lorenzo dun tiger
meldet sich per skype
zum glück mussten wir uns bisher noch
nicht entscheiden welche patienten wir
behandeln und welche nicht
aber wenn die zahlen weiter steigen wird
es unvermeidlich
ja frau war etwas was machten diese bio
damit liegen sie machen betroffen sie
machen auch bedrückt natürlich und wie
sie es vorhin schon gesorgt haben
bei uns ist es zum glück bis jetzt nicht
so weit gekommen und es ist eine tragik
die wir gar nicht so abschätzen können
was dort wirklich im einzelnen passiert
vor allen dingen im bericht heißt es
sie müssen nicht entscheiden wen sie nun
behandeln und wenig wenn man sich das in
manchen gegenden anschaut ist das denke
ich mittlerweile nicht mehr so
das heißt ärzte pfleger müssen
entscheiden wen nehmen wir auf das
klingt komisch aber bei wem lohnt es
sich ihn aufzunehmen und bei wem ist es
vielleicht schon zu spät und deswegen
machen wir es nicht mehr
und das ist natürlich eine tragik in
einem land aber auch für jeden ganz
persönlich und einzeln für den menschen
für die angehörigen dieses menschen der
was wir gar nicht abschätzen können was
das mit diesen menschen macht und wie
die dann auch später damit umgehen
werden und ob die genau diese menschen
dann eben doch posttraumatische
betroffen sein werden also sicher die
kranken aber auch das ärzte- und
pflegeteam das ist ja ein sehr die
sibirische sehr konkretes szenario der
angst gleichzeitig schwere nach so vage
unbestimmte ängste herum was die
wirtschaftliche situation angeht die
zukunft die arbeitsplätze und weiter wir
wissen viel dass nicht die philosophen
kirche und haider gaben mal
unterschieden zwischen der furcht und
der angst und die vorstands bestimmtes
eine spinne oder jetzt auch diese
krankheit da diese situation und die
angst ist eher diffus und unbestimmt war
kann man sagen was denn psychologisch
schlimmer ist eine konkrete furcht oder
eine allgemeine unbestimmte angst
also da würde ich aus sicht des menschen
der mit patienten zu tun hat schon sagen
die diffuse angst ist dies ist das
schlimmere andererseits man kann
schlimme dinge manchmal nämlich nicht
miteinander abwägen ich möchte sie haben
gefragt was solche bilder mit einem
machen und da denke ich doch dass manche
auch an die eigene sterblichkeit und an
die gefahr dass ist ein selber treffen
könnte denkt und das denkt natürlich
auch unserem unsere patientinnen und
patienten auch sie fixieren sich zum
teil auf diesen gedanken also anders
einerseits ist die diffuse angst und die
diffuse angst wird ja nun auch
unterstützt dadurch dass wir alle nicht
wissen wie wird das weitergehen
wie wird sich das entwickeln eine sehr
schlimme und schlecht zu handhabende
angelegenheit die ja manchmal auch zu
dann richtigen störungen und einem
behandlungsbedarf führt und die
konkreten befürchtungen die wirtschaft
darunter mein ich weiß nicht wie ich die
nächsten monate überhaupt noch zu
einkommen komme das sind alles sehr sehr
sehr sehr ernst zu nehmende dinge aber
da werden sich dann ja auch viele
hoffentlich viele menschen in der
gesellschaft um solche befürchtungen
kümmern das ist dann eine aufgabe von
politik verwaltung die diffusen ängste
das ist ja ein bisschen was was wir so
mitbekommen und was viele viele
befindlichkeiten ja verstärkt also
unsere der der menschen mit denen wir
zusammenarbeiten
ja angst ist ja eigentlich was gutes die
schützt uns in der regel vor gefahren
aber manchmal wird sie selbst zur gefahr
wenn es zu einer störung kommt warum
passiert das soli passiert das ja also
es hat viel damit zu tun dass es wie für
den menschen den es betrifft uns als
unkontrollierbar wahrgenommen wird und
das ist ja im moment in einer gewissen
weise auch so das heißt dass wir eine
gewisse sorgen dass wir gewisse ängste
im moment haben und zwar alle von uns
dass es vollkommen normal denn wir sind
in einer welt im moment in der wir ein
gewisses maß an kontrolle was wir vorher
dachten dass wir es hätten nicht haben
und feststellen müssen wir haben s bahn
wir haben es vielleicht sogar nie gehabt
und das wird wird einige menschen die
ein sehr großes kontrollbedürfnis haben
natürlich jetzt schwerer betreffen als
vielleicht andere die lernen damit
umzugehen dass es gewisse dinge gibt wo
man sich immer wieder neu drauf
einstellen muss das ist auch der vorteil
von uns menschen wir sind sehr
anpassungsfähig wir können uns schnell
auf neue lebenssituationen einstellen
wir sind zum glück eben auch intelligent
und haben auch also die kapazität neue
dinge zu entwickeln neue dinge wie soll
man sagen zu priorisieren vielleicht
auch also die telemedizin zum beispiel
war bei uns lange zeit stiefmütterlich
behandelt muss das heißt dass medizin
über über über distanz also telefon und
mich zwicken mit video telefon oder das
da gibt es andere länder die sind viel
weiter als wir und plötzlich klappt es
ja und plötzlich können wir eben genau
diese menschen die sich nicht mehr aus
dem haus trauen aus sorge und angst die
können sich jetzt plötzlich an einem
telefon melden oder an einem video
telefon und werden versuchen
früher saßen wie zu hause und wo nicht
versorgt wenn sie sich nicht raus
getraut haben das heißt wir versuchen
diese menschen abzufangen
das gelingt nicht bei allen das wird
auch nicht bei allen gelingen
das heißt es wird menschen geben wo sich
diese angst verselbstständigt wo
vielleicht schlafstörungen dazu kommen
wo vielleicht im verlauf der zeit auch
eine depressive entwicklung dazu kommt
also so vielleicht auch sogar im
schlimmsten fall gedanken gar nicht mehr
leben zu wollen also den sinn des lebens
selbst in frage zu stellen sie solche
patienten im moment an der klinik mehr
als am anfang wir haben ein kleines
bisschen den eindruck dass du diese
welle der starken angst mittlerweile
eben schon dem
weich dass menschen er vielleicht auch
depressive entwicklungen mitmachen
auch weil sie vielleicht schon
arbeitslos geworden sind oder weil sie
vielleicht schon vereins amt sind in
vier wochen kann man sehr wohl sehr
schnell vereinsamen oder und dh diese
menschen kommen zum glück zunehmend und
wir hoffen dass sie auch wirklich kommen
zu uns zu ihnen überall wo er selbst
angebote gibt es gibt extrem viele
hilfsangebote
was kann man tun damit es nicht so weit
kommt was empfehlen sie jetzt unseren
zuschauerinnen und zuschauer mit dem
jetzigen wie das ähnlich geht in einer
leichten form die ängstlich sehen die
niedergeschlagen sind ja also was ganz
sicher wichtig ist jeder von uns hat im
normalfall schon mal irgendeine art von
krise im leben erlebt ganz persönliche
krise und die haben viele von uns gut
gemeistert und das heißt es geht um sich
darauf zurück zu besinnen wie habe ich
das denn geschafft
dann geht es darum eben mit freunden in
kontakt zu bleiben enge bezugspersonen
weiterhin zu kontaktieren
dort den die sorgen auszutauschen die
ängste auszutauschen
es geht auch darum eine ganz gute
tagesstruktur aufrecht zu erhalten
vielleicht wenn wir mal in zeiten der
pest zurück gucken die die das decameron
kennen also ein buch mit 100 geschichten
sind zehn leute einfach aufs land
gefahren das sollen wir alle nicht aber
die haben was haben die gemacht die
haben sich geschichten erzählt und die
haben eine feste tagesstruktur gehabt
diese zehn leute wir können vielleicht
zu fünft in einer wohnung das gemeinsam
machen und das hat denen geholfen beim
überleben auch andere themen sie waren
ja nicht mehr im festgebiet aber die
haben mit einer guten tagesstruktur mit
dem dass sie wertschätzend miteinander
umgegangen sind mit dem dass sie sich
auch geschichten erzählt haben haben die
die sehr sehr schwere zeit gemeistert
ja ich will vielleicht als kleinigkeiten
noch zusetzen weil nicht unter das alles
unterstützen was sie sagen das ist auch
dass ich keinen druck aufbauen sollte in
einem selber jetzt in dieser krise
besonders kreativ zu sein besonders gut
alles zu verkraften es ist eine zeit von
verzichten es ist eine zeit in der man
immer wieder sich eigentlich den wird
das schade das ist jetzt so läuft schade
dass wir ein bisschen eingesperrt sind
schade dass wir menschen nicht sehen
können oder auch ganz andere dinge und
und dann aber auch nicht den druck jetzt
müssen wir darauf jetzt müssen wir in
der zeit unbedingt noch eine sprache
lernen jetzt müssen wir in der zeit
unbedingt noch den garten besser pflegen
also es kann auch mal eine zeit sein in
der man keine extra vorhaben macht
bei mir ist es so schnell es geht vielen
so es gibt so ein andrang szenario das
total schrecklich ist wenn man jetzt wie
ich an meine eigenen eltern denken zum
beispiel dass die ihren coup 19
erkranken können im spital sterben
würden alleine
ich kann nicht abschied nehmen haben sie
da wohl nicht mehr richtig gesehen auch
die beerdigung ist irgendwie nur ein
ganz enger kreis die trauerarbeit muss
ich alleine machen mit familie ist das
nicht eine heillose überforderung unsere
psyche etwas hat es ist interessant dass
sie das jetzt als der sohn der eltern
sagen weil wir müssten bei so etwas auch
immer fragen was die menschen in dieser
generation sagen also wenn es um
mögliches sterben geht oder auch reales
sterben wir haben ja diese bilder auch
diesbezüglich gesehen aus bergamo dann
sollte man schon an beide seiten denken
nämlich was ist was sind die bedürfnisse
derjenigen denen es schlechter geht und
noch schlechter geht die und was sind
die bedürfnisse von uns angehörigen also
die wir wissen dass alles was mit dem
tod oder dem abschied nehmen zu tun hat
ja und trauer dann zu tun hat sehr
kultur gebunden auch ist uns zum
beispiel das abschied nehmen ist ein
begriff der jetzt hineingekommen ist in
unserer kultur und es sieht fast so aus
man muss es machen aber die frage ist ob
nicht die betroffenen das auch so
brauchen es gibt häufig ein rück ziehen
der menschen die ganz kurz vor dem tod
stehen die häufig das gefühl haben ich
brauche jetzt gar nicht mehr so den
kontakt zu den anderen viele reden ja
dann auch gar nicht mehr auch außerhalb
von kurve 19
und wenn dann haben sie manchmal wenn
man sie befragt hat noch eher ängste um
ihre angehörigen dass sie so stark
leiden und es ist gar nicht so deren
bedürfnis dieses der verabschiedung
sondern es ist eher das bedürfnis von
uns angehörigen der vorab der
verabschiedung sollten wir das bedürfnis
der betroffenen ernst nehmen so umso
höher gewichten als würden sie sagen ein
bisschen schauen dass immer wenn es um
tod sterben trauer geht ist auch sich so
etwas wie kulturelle bedürfnisse
herausgebildet haben die man aber auch
nochmal auf grund der dessen was die
psychologie sagt was läuft dafür was
laufen für prozesse dabei auch noch mal
relativieren kann also ich glaube das
ist sehr sehr hilfreich war dass den in
bergamo ist nach diesen kontakt über
über videotelefonie gab aber ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass manche der
betroffenen auch trotzdem in ruhe
gestorben sind und dass ihr die
angehörigen die nach generation die
bleibt auf ihren problem setzen
sie sind ein international anerkannter
führender trauma forscher
die haben schon am anfang kurz über
traumata gesprochen wie groß ist die
gefahr wenn jemand so etwas überlebt so
eine intensivstation
das dann trauma zurück bleibt
sie ist
etwas weniger ahlmann als man gemeinhin
glaubt sie hängt davon ab wie übrige
faktoren vorhanden sind ob es ein mensch
sehr isoliert vorne weg war und sie
hängt von situativen faktoren ab also es
ist nicht so dass jeder mensch der ein
dem tod von der klinge gesprungen ist
oder der den tod ganz nahe als unfall
oder dramatischen tod erlebt hat
unwillkürlich eine traumafolgestörungen
entwickelt sondern es gibt auch viel
resilienz viele psychische
widerstandsfähigkeit und ein hauptfaktor
dabei ist wie weit man eingebettet ist
in familie in freunde wie viel man
darüber reden kann was ihm passiert ist
so dass es nicht unbedingt ein eine
ausgeliefertsein gibt dass das unbedingt
so kommt dass wir alle hinterher
traumatisiert sein werden und die haupt
aber genau dieses eingebettet sein fehlt
uns doch jetzt wenn wir isoliert im
spital liegen oder isoliert zu hause
sind ja aber dann gibt es vielleicht die
situativen faktoren dass man sagt ich
habe mich so gefreut über die die
pflegenden und die ärzte und das ist
nicht gesagt dass das dann immer die die
großfamilie oder die kleinfamilie
kernfamilie das ist auf die ankommen
sondern man kann dann schon auch
würdigen dass es dass andere menschen
unter gefahr sitzung ihres eigenen
lebens sich um ein gekümmert haben dass
sie eine nette worte gesagt haben
also da bin ich nicht so bin ich nicht
der meinung dass das alles in eine nur
negative richtung laufen muss wie würde
sich ein trauma überhaupt äußern und wie
behält man noch träume also es gibt
verschiedene definitionen die die
definition die sich in den letzten
jahren als die beste herausstellt ist
dass man das ein bisschen im
zirkelschluss definiert nämlich ein
traum ein längerfristiges trauma ist das
dann was mit flashbacks einhergeht
flashbacks sind
erinnerungs zustände als ob man jetzt
noch mal in der in der situation wäre
als ob man nochmal in der situation ist
mit allen ihren ängsten
also das heißt man sieht nicht nur die
bilder die empfindungen sondern glaubt
noch immer genau und das ist ein ja
manche träume opfergruppen kennen das
sehr sehr gut
das sind eben die opfergruppen mit
sexualisierter gewalt albträume spielen
eine rolle
also dass man dann lange zeit im leben
noch zb an seine eigene intensivstation
denkt und auch erschreckt barkeit und
eine allgemeine erhöhte wachsamkeit dass
man nirgendwo sich ganz vertrauensvoll
aufhalten kann weil man immer denkt
etwas kommt und diese dinge sind im
eigentlichen kern eine posttraumatische
belastungsstörung die wirklich dann auch
hartnäckig ist die lebensqualität
einschränkt aber für posttraumatische
belastungsstörungen gibt es inzwischen
gute therapien die im grunde genommen
darauf zu laufen dass man durch erzählen
durch darüber sprechen seine
verdrängungsmechanismen abzubauen dass
doch wieder in seinen lebens leben
integrieren kann
ich möchte mit ihnen noch ein bisschen
jetzt von der voller angst vom drama weg
hin zu dieser enge die jetzt viele
familien paare auch spüren
die forschungsstelle sotomo hat zweimal
eine umfrage gemacht jetzt in dieser
krise die letzte kann ich diese woche
haben am mittwoch und wir schauen uns da
mal kurz die grafik an
was die funken sind dieses zuhause
bleiben und da könnte man jetzt viele
sagen ich picke nur zwei raus das eine
ist sicher der bewegungsmangel oder
viele menschen beschäftigt
das eingesperrt fühlen sieht man hat
zugenommen innerhalb von zwei wochen und
auch die belastung durch kinderbetreuung
und homeschooling und aus philosoph
kommt mir immer der satz von poser in
der sie in den sinn
in seinem theaterstück wie kloo
geschlossene gesellschaft schreibt hat
die hölle das sind die anderen
und ich habe mich gefragt warum halten
wir das so schlecht aus auch mit unseren
liebsten eingesperrt zu sein
viele paare und familien warum fährt das
uns menschen so schwer wir sind es nicht
gewohnt wir sind es vielleicht über die
generationen auch immer weniger gewohnt
früher lebten mehrere generationen in
einem haushalt es war normal ganz
großeltern eltern vielleicht sogar noch
die crew urgroßeltern und und die kinder
und alle zusammen oft auch auf engem
raum oder unser raum bedürfnis hat sich
in den in den letzten generationen immer
vergrößert wir leben auf immer größeren
raum wie wir wissen ehrlicherweise doch
oft gar nicht was genau machen die
kinder alles in der schule
ich hatte es vorhin schon gesagt keiner
von uns ist lehrer und plötzlich sollen
wir unseren kindern als lehrer etwas
beibringen zum teil sollen dafür sorgen
dass sie etwas vielleicht auch neu
lernen was wir vielleicht selber nicht
mal wissen
da werden manche eltern an grenzen
stoßen
dass sie da gibt es auch berichte dazu
dass dass das verhältnis zwischen den
kindern und den eltern zum teil auch
schädigen kann weil die kinder plötzlich
merken meine eltern wissen das ja selber
nicht
die wissen gar nicht was ich da in der
schule handy haben das selber vielleicht
ja auch nie gelernt es gibt viele neue
dinge die man in der schule lernt und
das ist ein problem
zudem die kinder haben die haben den
natürlichen bewegungsdrang und den
können die jetzt auch nicht ausleben und
da ist es natürlich sehr wichtig dass
irgendwie in der wohnung oder eben doch
mit ums haus rennen oder um das karree
wo sie wohnen doch mal raus zu rennen
raus zu lassen und was enorm wichtig ist
wir haben doch normalerweise in unserem
leben jeder zeiten in denen wir allein
sind und wenn wir das jetzt nicht für
uns etablieren haben wir das plötzlich
nicht mehr
und das ist etwas
wo wir uns vielleicht besinnen oder wo
wir normalerweise vielleicht auch mal
wut rauslassen oder mit uns mit uns
selbst ein zwiegespräch führen und das
geht oft verloren wenn man sich
vorstellt ist wohnen jetzt vielleicht
vier fünf leute auf engstem raum und man
plant nicht bewusst ein
jeder darf auch mal allein sein jeder
darf auch mal seinen ganz persönlichen
freiraum haben
man wird sich mal trifft man werde immer
gesehen worden wird gespiegelt ja auch
dass ich würde mich vielleicht doch
gerne mal auf diese philosophische
provokation von setra einlassen mit der
hölle
sie haben das natürlich jetzt er so für
die familie erzählt in der die wenn die
kinder klein sind oder auch später mit
ihren bedürfnissen kommen die ruhe
stören das ist nur die halbe halle
reicht dann manchmal doch wenn da so ein
ehepaar zusammensitzt dass sich andeutet
miteinander und die dann wirklich den
eindruck haben hart was sitze ich mit
dieser person war zusammen diese person
stört mich schon lange und ich glaube
und das ist auch so meine lesart von
diesem stück die geschlossene
gesellschaft von strip da kommen dann
lebenslügen dazu das ist lebenslügen
dazu dass es natürlich auch wieder ein
überspitzter begriff sondern das hin zur
dinge von wievielen meiner wünsche die
ich früher mal hatte habe ich durch
kompromisse in meiner partnerschaft
aufgegeben und auf einmal kommen sie
kompromisse irgendwie foul vor und man
denkt man könnte das auch anders lösen
und man wollte vielleicht doch eine ganz
andere partnerin partner haben oder mit
anderen eigenschaften und dann gibt es
ja auch den effekt dass man wenn man
lange zeit ein paar ist auch menschen
dann sich gegenseitig stören mit
bestimmten dingen und das alles wird
dann in solchen situationen besonders
stark von daher ich nehme diese
provokation gern entgegen auch wenn sie
ein gewisses extrem ist natürlich
verdient denn die meisten menschen von
uns werden schon die zweisamkeit und
familienzusammenhalt gut meistern
aber die frage ob man in dieser
extremsituation jetzt die echte person
besser kennenlernt oder ob es eine
verzerrte person ist dass das gegenüber
sie haben gesagt die kinder lernen die
eltern jetzt besser kennt so die diese
illusion werden auch entzaubert jemand
aufgebaut hat etwas hat was sie da
fragen ist natürlich eigentlich dann
auch wieder noch eine philosophische
frage was ist nicht die echte person was
ist die wahre person
und da haben wir uns schon auch für
unsere prof denke ich zurecht gelegt
dass das ist eine ganz schwierige frage
also man immer außer frage es ist
wahrscheinlich auch die falsche frage
sondern es sind einfach verschiedene
aspekte die man mit einander kennenlernt
wie sie alle sind ja eine multi zitat
von von bestimmten
charaktereigenschaften
persönlichkeitseigenschaften und wenn
menschen denken jetzt lerne ich dadurch
meinen waren partner kennen ich glaube
da wäre mehr reflexion das bessere zu
sagen das kann jetzt nicht die stunde
der wahrheit sein dieser ausnahme zu das
ist beruhigend zu lang wird die
scheidungsrate steigen ist zu befürchten
dass das sein könnte gleichwohl geht es
ja auch eben darum jetzt nicht kopflos
zu sagen oh das ist jetzt mein partner
den ich jetzt in diesen vier wochen
vielleicht anders kennengelernt habe
denn es wird ja wieder zeiten geben wo
man vielleicht wieder mehr räumliche
trennung hat wo vielleicht wieder mehr
freunde auch mit interagieren so dass
man auch gewisse konflikte vielleicht
auch mit wieder mit anderen
vertrauenspersonen besprechen kann vor
besprechen kann so dass es
wahrscheinlich auch nach der krise
wieder eine gewisse beruhigung in vielen
beziehungen geben könnte wenn man nicht
als schnellschuss dann sagt jetzt
trennen wir uns weil jetzt in den vier
wochen haben wir festgestellt es geht
gar nicht
ja ich denke auch das wird eine gewisse
katalysatorfunktion haben diese diese
zeit der gemeinsamen isolation aber wir
kennen dann auch solche effekte das
vielleicht scheidungen er schneller
danach sind die ansonsten sich auf die
nächsten drei jahre verteilt würden und
das ist dann eher eine rasante eine
niedrige rate danach darf entscheidung
geben würde
also ich glaube nicht dass das jetzt
grundsätzlich unser zusammenleben auf
dauer und auch unser partnerschaftliches
zusammen eben auf dauer beschädigt es
ist ja keine situation für die ewigkeit
sagt was muss man sich bewusst machen
der bundesrat wird nächste woche über
lockerungsmaßnahmen informieren dennoch
fragen sich viele wie lange dauert das
genau noch was kommt danach
es sind so man wird sich schmerzlich
bewusst dass die zukunft ungewiss ist
und dass wir sie nicht kontrollieren
können jetzt aus philosoph denke ich das
ist doch eine lektion die wir schon
längst gelernt haben soll
ja wir vergessen sie schnell wieder
wir sind ja also wenn sie sich überlegen
an was sie sich erinnern oder dann
erinnern sie sich doch im normalfall
wenn ich sie frage was haben sie letzte
woche mittwoch gegessen werden sie sagen
keine ahnung
wenn das jetzt aber mit einer sehr
positiven emotionen verknüpft gewesen
wäre weil sie jemand gegen eine freudige
überraschung für sie gemacht hat müssten
sie sehr wohl noch was sie gegessen
haben das heißt diese erinnerung weil
sie emotional und haben an bord ist wird
eine gewisse zeit lang bleiben aber wenn
die emotionen anfangen zu verblassen
werden wir auch die erinnerung an das
verlieren was wir jetzt erlebt haben und
dann sind wir vielleicht wir sind fall
auch fantasiewesen oder wir haben die
fantasie uns die welt so bunt zu machen
wie wir sie uns wünschen
und das heißt wir werden auch wieder die
dinge die negativ sind anfangen
auszublenden weil sie uns stören in
unserem alltag wir werden wieder lernen
auf das positive zu fokussieren und die
negativen dinge vielleicht auch zu
verdrängen und das haben wir schon oft
in unserer geschichte gemacht haben dann
wenig draus gelernt
es wäre schön wir könnten langfristig
etwas daraus lernen
ich weiß nicht ob ich da so guter
hoffnung sein soll dass wir das weit in
die zukunft mitnehmen können sondern es
entsteht wieder diese blase dieser luxus
auf diese oberflächlichkeit vielleicht
vielleicht wenn wir pech haben wir da so
weitergehen wie vorher
er merke sie haben über weisheit
promoviert habe ich gelesen es ja ein
philosophischer begriff eine weise
person wäre die von dieser pandemie
genauso überrascht und in der krise
geworfenen gewesen wie ideale wie wir
normalsterblichen oder wie würde eine
weise person an dass mit dieser krise
umgehen eine weise person hätte auch es
nicht vorher gesehen was das ist so eine
entwicklung geben wird denn eine weise
person hat keine extra
informationsquellen aber was sie vor als
stichwort gesagt haben das ist natürlich
dann ein ein merkmal von weisheit
nämlich das aushalten können von
unkontrollierbarkeit und von
unsicherheit das gehört unbedingt dazu
und ich hoffe mir ich hoffe schon dass
also eine lehre die nicht unbedingt im
alltagsleben weil wir da viel vergessen
wie sie es beschrieben haben aber eine
eine eine philosophische eine eine
reflektierende lehre sein wird eben dass
es überraschungen geben wird das
unsicherheiten auszuhalten sind und dass
wir nichts dagegen tun können also wir
können kleinigkeiten tun wir können alle
diese schutzmaßnahmen machen weiß hat
ansonsten ist aber natürlich auch noch
hat noch mehr mehrere komponenten dazu
gehört dann empathie
dazu gehört aber auch dass man
komplexität mit immer in rechnung stellt
also dass dinge nicht einfach schnell zu
erklären sind und häufig verschiedene
faktoren haben
es gehört viel lebens wissen dazu also
wir haben ja alle wahrscheinlich mal
überlegt was etwas vergleichen wir das
denn jetzt in unserem leben
einige von uns sind draufgekommen je
nach generation tschernobyl wobei dann
mussten wir auch schon unser gedächtnis
anschmeißen was war eigentlich kurz nach
tschernobyl
also alles das gehört zur weisheit aber
es ist schon interessant dieses
aushalten können von etwas
unkontrollierbaren das
auch ein zentraler bestandteil und auch
dieses bewusstsein der eigenen
sterblichkeit dass sie angesprochen
haben
habt ihr wahrscheinlich auch mit
weisheit zu tun denn wenn man das leben
als ganzes betrachtet ist irgendwann zu
ende
und vielleicht vergessen wir dass die
meiste zeit des lebens und in solchen
krisenzeiten wird uns das wieder bewusst
ja vielleicht werden wir dankbarer demut
fiel oft in den diskussionen jetzt meine
der begriff demut ja der viel oft aber
der ist auch ein begriff den natürlich
auch politiker auch in den mund nehmen
dann finden wir das auch sympathisch
demut ist denke ich ein begriff den man
in den mund nehmen kann wenn man ein
entscheidungsträger insbesondere war und
sagt jetzt kann man gar nicht so viel
entscheiden und jetzt muss man darauf
hören was die wissenschaftler sagen wir
müssen uns jeden tag neu einstellen wir
müssen demütig sein als persönlicher
erfahrung ist es glaube ich eher dieses
allgemeine reflektieren vielleicht
philosophischer werden was überhaupt für
manche von psychischen störungen auch
eine gute attitüde ist wenn man lernt
philosophischer was ein bisschen zu sein
ja dass man für sich selber fest halt
durch welche art und weise bin ich aus
meinen ängsten herausgekommen wie habe
ich das geschafft mich von den ängsten
zu entfernen aber auch zb das mit der
sterblichkeit dass man dinge
relativieren kann und sagen kann was wir
haben hier eine krisensituation viele
von uns haben verzichte aber was ist
damit wenn wir in unserer nahen umgebung
jemand haben der vielleicht sogar auch
schon noch mitten im leben steht
elternteil von kindern ist wie wir das
aus italien gehört haben von den
pflegekräften und da stirbt jemand also
auch manchmal dieses relativieren können
auch das gehört zu so einer
philosophischen haltung habe das ist ja
ein gewaltakt auch schwierig also ich
hatte auch persönlich diese situation
ich war draußen am anfang und dieser
krise und wir haben ein bisschen erzählt
mit einer anderen mutter und der gesagt
wir kennen diese quarantäne situation
schon lange mein sohn hat leukämie ist
seit fünf modern und das
relativiert das ganze natürlich extrem
und trotzdem findet man die eigene
probleme haben nach ein gewisses gewicht
gefühlt obwohl man das rational liegen
wir relativieren kann
das ist erstmal völlig okay dass man an
seinen eigenen problemen dran ist aber
wir haben ja alle ein bisschen ein
verlauf und wir haben es gibt eine halbe
stunde später nachdem man so etwas denkt
und es gibt eine stunde später und es
gibt ein abend an dem manche von uns
manchmal auch noch eine tages übersicht
machen und wenn wir dann ein bisschen
davon wegkommen von diesen was uns
selber als aktuelle probleme bedrängt
das wäre schon ein fortschritt
ich glaube wir sehen ist ja auch viel
also sie haben bezüglich der weisheit ja
auch das inbegriff der empathie gebracht
also das mitfühlen mit anderen oder und
ich glaube das sehen wir in der krise
schon auch sehr ausgeprägt dass es dass
es vielen gelingt mit den anderen
mitzufühlen und sei das im kleinen sei
das auch im großen
also ich denke wir haben viele große
kleine laute leise helden im moment die
überall herumlaufen die dass die
weiterhin ab zum beispiel ihrer arbeit
nachgehen
aber es sind auch helden die die
risikopatienten sind uns zu hause
bleiben weil sie wissen dass sie
risikopatienten sind und ich glaube uns
das bewusst zu machen dass die meisten
von uns im moment irgendwie im alltag
auch kleine heldentaten vollbringen und
auch stolz sein dürfen darauf dass sie
diese kleinen heldentaten vollbringen
das ist denke ich wichtig um auch der
angst entgegenzustehen um der
depressivität entgegenzustehen um
vielleicht auch mal den frust dem ärger
dass man bei dem schönen wetter immer
noch drin hockt entgegenzustehen sich
selbst bewusst zu machen ich habe auch
als mensch als individuum schon ganz
viel mitgeholfen dass es eben besser
wird indem man zu hause sitzt sie nicht
das ist das paradoxe oder oder sonst
solidarisch sein in dem man distanz zu
den anderen
das ist sehr schwierig
ich möchte mit ihnen jetzt gegen ende
des gesprächs nach müssen auch die
gesellschaftliche dimension kommen das
gericht immer wieder krisen epidemien
krankheiten und so weiter und die
gesellschaft hat oft etwas daraus
gelernt dass haben sich dinge verändert
haben sie hypothesen was was bleiben
könnte nach dieser krise auf
gesellschaftlicher ebene wie wir uns
verändern könnten er merken ja ich
gleich einmal an wir haben es schon
gesagt ich will es hier noch mal an
dieser stelle weil es passt wiederholen
nämlich dass wir überrascht werden
können über dinge die wir uns alle nicht
ausgemalt haben die weiterhin kommen
werden und es kann ja gut sein das ist
alle drei jahre ein durch einen neuen
virus der irgendwo auf der welt entsteht
eine eine pandemie gibt also diese
überraschung ist das eine das zweite ist
schon auch die sterblichkeit von uns das
möchte ich schon noch sagen dass wir
schon eine gefährdete gefährdet sind und
dass das zuschlagen kann und dass man
manchmal wenig dagegen tun kann also das
war vor 100 jahren mit der spanischen
grippe ja noch schlimmer da begann
morgens die symptome und und am
nachmittag waren viele schon tot und ich
denke auch schon dass wir schauen
müssten was jetzt naturwissenschaftler
und sagen woher kommt dieser art das
nach dem vor 150 jahren die bakterien in
ihrer deutlichkeit gebannt wurden robert
koch wir haben es geschafft pasteur dass
wir antibiotika haben und von daher gibt
es pest und cholera nicht mehr
und woher kommt es jetzt dass die viren
auf uns überspringen und von daher auch
also in einem vereinten bemühungen dann
naturwissenschaftler die heilenden
berufe die gesellschaft zu schauen wie
wir etwas verhindern können in dieser
beziehung
und was denken sie wochen liegt das mit
den wehren sich die prothese ich nehme
staat das was ich aus der presse weil
zur kenntnis dass ist die zurückdrängung
der biotope in der bestimmte lebewesen
sich noch zurückziehen konnten sei es in
asien sei es in südamerika dass die mit
einer veränderten viren mutation und
einem überspringen von tierischen viren
auf menschliche körper zu tun hat und
von daher nehme ich deren idee sehr sehr
ernst das wir schauen müssen wie wir
diese welt
in dieser welt ist schaffen dass wir das
bio reservat größeren ausmaßes gibt wenn
das wirklich ein grund ist dass die
viren jetzt in den letzten 100 jahren
saß ja so ein unwesen treiben es gab
auch stimmen die gesagt haben wir haben
es mit der effizienz mit der
beschleunigung übertrieben wir haben
jetzt die krise zeigt das system lief am
limit auch mit der globalisierung
vielleicht wie sehen sie das wird danach
irgendwie es um entschleuniger für
bestimmte menschen zustand öfter da sein
oder wird sich irgendwie unsere
lebensform so müssten verändern das
bewusstsein verändern zumindest in den
nächsten monaten
ich kann mir vorstellen in den nächsten
monaten wird sich da etwas ändern es
wird habe ich nicht den eindruck viel an
der gesamt globalisierung ändern es wird
vielleicht wieder ein bisschen eine
gewisse dezentralisierung von gewissen
dingen geben ich meine wir haben jetzt
gesehen medikamente oder rohstoffe für
medikamente kommen hauptsächlich aus dem
chinesischen raum für gewisse produkte
das kommt aus dem chinesischen raum
da geht es nicht um nationalismus
sondern da geht es darum dass man dass
es doch auch sinnvoll wäre auf jedem
kontinent zumindestens vielleicht einen
produzenten gewisse dinge zu haben was
ich mir ganz persönlich wünschen würde
wir haben jetzt eine situation in der
wir extrem
viel über psychische auswirkungen
sprechen
wir haben noch nie im leben glaube ich
also ich habe es noch nicht erlebt so
viel in der presse im fernsehen und
überall über psychische auswirkungen
eines zustandes geredet und das heißt
wir haben eine situation in der viel
viel weniger stigmatisiert wird als auch
zu anderen zeiten und das würde ich mir
persönlich wünschen dass wir das
schaffen in die zukunft zu übertragen
das dass es menschen gibt die psychisch
belastet sind und dass es okay ist wenn
sich so jemand hilfe holt und das ist
auch okay ist wenn wir darüber sprechen
gibt es so etwas wie gesellschaftliche
resilienz diese widerstandsfähigkeit sie
haben das angetönt für die eigene psyche
scheint das zu geben die hängt von
bestimmten sachen aber aus gesellschaft
können wir das auch lernen
das wird es schon geben ich meine
allianz tochter immer dann aufwand wenn
sie gefordert ist und von daher wir
hatten ja so eine krise noch nicht jetzt
bei uns und ich glaube schon
jetzt komme ich auf einen aspekt der
vielleicht überraschend ist nämlich dass
dass diese pandemie und erreicht in
einem in einer zeit in der wir digital
so miteinander verbunden sind und in dem
hier in der schweiz wie auch den luxus
international gesehen von ganz viel
breitbandversorgung haben also das
erlaubt einfach soziale kontakte und
soziale kontakte das ist die der
hauptfaktor von resilienz also von daher
sind wir eigentlich schon ganz gut
gerüstet denn wir wären nicht gut
beraten wenn es das nicht gäbe wenn
vielleicht noch das telefonsystem
zusammenbrechen würde
und ein anderer faktor der residenz ist
vielleicht auch dieses sich eingestehen
und dieses auch öffentlich machen und
auch in den medien dass uns das ganze
auch psychisch tangiert dass wir diese
sensibilität für die eigene gefühlswelt
und für die ups and downs
auch wir haben gar nicht heute den wort
das wort benutzt lagerkoller das immer
mal wieder kommt wenn man dann eben
allein ist und dass man das auch mit
anderen ausspricht
also ich könnte mir vorstellen dass ja
diese digitale umgebung soziale kontakte
die ja möglich sind ganz ein ganz ganz
ganz wichtiger teil der residenz sind
letzte kurze frage an sie beide diese
vier wochen lockdown hatten die in ihrem
persönlichen leben auch positive seiten
gibt es dinge die sie jetzt anders
machen werden
nach dieser zeit breit ich schätze die
zeit mit meiner familie mehr als freue
ich habe sie auch vorher geschätzt aber
ich schätze sie jetzt noch mehr und das
ist für mich eine sehr was sehr
positives ich freue mich auch darauf
wenn wir wieder mehr ausgeben könnt das
ist natürlich so aber man kann auch
lernen mit dem umzugehen was man hat und
auch das schätze ich dass es nicht die
reise sein muss dass es nicht irgendein
event oder sonst irgendetwas sein muss
sondern dass man sich auch an kleinen
dingen sehr wohl freuen kann
genügsamkeit daher merken was werden sie
anders machen
ach ich möchte mal jetzt doch nicht an
mich nur denken ich beobachte aber mit
großer freude oder mit mit interesse das
doch auch männer und väter mehr auf ihre
kinder jetzt geworfen werden und mein
sohn ist 35 also das ist ja nun schon
gar nicht mehr relevant in diesem
zusammenhang aber ich finde das schön
wie auf einmal ich um mich herum sehe
dass väter sich mit den kindern einen
ganzen tag lang beschäftigen nicht nur
am wochenende
spaziergänge machen sport machen und ich
denke das ist schon mal eine kleinigkeit
von einem positiven erfahrung von der
ich übrigens hoffe dass das die
betreffenden sowohl die kinder die väter
als auch die die mütter auch irgendwie
in die zukunft transportieren werden
sehr schön herr merkel freiheit vielen
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
ja danke auch im fürs mitdenken und den
schwierigen zeiten ist es ja bekanntlich
ratsam einen klaren kopf zu bewahren und
darum gibt es nächste woche an dieser
stelle einen crashkurs in logischen
denkens und jetzt gleich folgt der oster
segen des papstes aus rom
bleiben sie also dran und vor allem
bleiben sie gesund
[Musik]